I think the most difficult
part of cleaning an iPhone
is just knowing that you're touching
somebody else's grime and muck.
It's disgusting, really,
when you think about it.
I can already see that we've
got quite a lot of gunk
in the ear speaker and the
speaker grilles themselves,
so hopefully there'll be
some gunk in there to see
and we can give it a real
good clean-out as well.
Lint builds up from
inside somebody's pocket,
and over time, when the
charging cable's inserted,
taken out, reinserted, all that happens
is it just compacts into
the charge port itself
and leaves this sort of mess behind
and all this lint.
Over time, it just compacts.
Every time you put it on charge,
it just compacts deep down into the port.
When you start noticing the
ear speaker becomes quiet,
the microphone, people can't hear you,
or it's not charging correctly,
you might have to stand on your head
and do a backflip just to make it charge,
that's probably when you
need to start thinking
about cleaning out that charge
port or the ear speaker.
I'm using this little BGA scraper,
which is typically designed
for scraping the resin overfill
or underfill from logic boards,
but it doubles up as a
really, really useful tool
for cleaning out these charging ports.
The stuff, what we usually
find in the charging ports
and crevices of the phone,
is mostly either pocket gunk
or fluff from the bottom of handbags.
I mean, I'm not a forensic scientist,
but I'm going to guess there's dog hairs,
dust, fluff.
I don't really know
how to describe the ...
the fibers what are in there.
Other things that we've
found in the phones,
rice is quite common when phones
have become water damaged,
because they'll stick the phone in rice.
That doesn't work, by the way.
We did find some weed in one of them,
and it looked like they must
have been keeping the stash
in the pocket, and it,
the same thing again.
There was weed inside the charge port.
So, this iPhone 7 has come
in for a battery replacement,
and as you can see,
it's absolutely full of dust,
lint, hair, wood chip, feathers;
you name it, it's in this phone.
Well, I can see that the
screen's been replaced before.
I think they've probably
just never replaced
the dust seal what's on there.
This is really common
because, believe it or not,
not many repair places will replace
that dust and moisture seal.
The best way to clean
something like this out
is to get all the thick stuff,
probably with the dust blower.
There is definitely a risk
that this dust could cause a short circuit
on the motherboard.
It's going to put lots of strain
on peripheral hardware
like the loudspeaker.
It's going to be quiet.
The vibration motor's not
going to work very well,
or you're going to get funny sounds
from the vibration motor.
A lot of people think that
it's just for moisture.
It keeps a seal between the screen
and the chassis of the phone,
which, out of the factory, is designed
so that it's sealed away from
elements like dust and dirt.
Ear-speaker cleaning is one of the things
what we get all the time
where somebody's phone's really quiet.
10 to 20% of the phones what we get in
actually need cleaning out.
The easiest way to clean
out an iPhone ear speaker
is using some isopropyl alcohol.
The customer will ask for
a ear-speaker replacing,
but in reality, it just
needs cleaning out.
And even if we did
replace the ear speaker,
it probably would still be quiet
because that mesh is just
bunged up and gunked up.
Then we loosen up the
gunk with a toothbrush.
Make sure that it's not the toothbrush
that you've used this
morning to brush your teeth.
And then we play this sound,
which plays a 165-hertz sound,
[sound humming]
which acts as a sort of
ultrasonic cleaner.
For the most part, I think
that the most common thing
that gets in ear speaker
is probably earwax.
I don't really want to think
about what else it could be,
what's getting in there,
because it's, yeah, it's gross.
We use two different types of brushes.
For the softer brush we use a toothbrush,
and then a slightly more stiff one
is this small horsehair brush.
The vibrations act as an agitator,
and it loosens the dirt,
what's in those tiny little
gaps in the ear speaker.
So, the cloth over the speaker,
we add a little bit of alcohol onto there.
And the way that that works
is just adding a finer
layer of cleaning stuff
just to get any remaining
bits of dust out of there.
So, for this one, it's a iPhone 11 Pro,
and it's got a little bit of
gunk in the speaker grille
at the bottom, which would
make the phone pretty quiet.
This is very similar
to what gets built up
inside the charge port.
It's just pocket gunk.
The best tool for this one
is the sharp, pointed BGA scraper again.
The debris in these holes
will often look like
a browny, sort of beige color,
whereas the actual speakers are black,
so you'll know that
you've got it in there.
I sort of got involved
with fixing friends' and family's phones,
sorting out technical problems for them,
and once I started learning
about phone repair,
I just got deeper and deeper into it.
It's like a rabbit hole,
and I just got fully sucked down it.
We receive about 20 iPhones
per week in the post,
and we probably take in
from walk-in customers between
five and 15 phones a day.
You get lots of instances where somebody
might bring a phone in, and
it might be a minor thing,
and they say, "Oh, look, my
phone's completely dead."
And it's really good to
see people very happy
once you've repaired their devices.
The buildup inside the
charge port usually occurs
when it's been placed
into your pocket. [laughs]
Can't even keep a straight face
when I say it anymore. Right.